so today I thought we talked about
generative adversarial networks because
they're really cool and they've they can
do a lot of really cool things people
have used them for all kinds of things
things like you know you draw a sketch
of a shoe and it will render you an
actual picture of a shoe or a handbag
they're fairly low-resolution right now
but it's very impressive the way that
they can produce real quite good-looking
images you could make a neural network
that's a classifier right you give it
lots and lots of pictures of cats and
lots and lots of pictures of dogs and
you say you know you present it with a
picture of a cat and it says it outputs
a number let's say between zero and one
and zero represents cats and one
represents dogs and so you give it a cat
and it puts out one and you say no
that's not right should be zero and you
keep training it until eventually it can
tell the difference right so somewhere
inside that network it's it must have
formed some model of what cats are and
what dogs are at least as far as images
of images of them are concerned but that
model really you can only really use it
to classify things you can't say ok draw
me a new cat picture drew me a cat
picture I haven't seen before it doesn't
know how to do that so quite often you
want a model that can generate new
samples you have so you give it a bunch
of samples from a particular
distribution and you want it to give you
more samples which are also from that
same distribution so it has to learn the
underlying structure of what you've
given it and that's kind of tricky
actually there's a lot of well there's a
lot of challenges involved in that well
let's be honest I don't think as a human
you can find that tricky you know if if
I I know what a cat looks like but being
not the greatest artist in the world I'm
not sure that I could draw you a decent
cat so you know that this is this is not
confined to just computing is it this
yeah that's true that's really true but
if
you take let's do like a really simple
example of a generative model say you
you give your network one thing it looks
like this and then you give it another
one you're like these are your training
samples looks like this you give it
another one that looks like this and
then what are those dots in the system's
instances of something on two dimensions
yeah I mean right now it's literally
just data we just it doesn't matter what
it is just some yeah these are these are
data points and so these are the things
you're giving it and then it will learn
you can train it you will learn a model
and the model it might learn is
something like this right
it's figured out that these dots all lie
along a path and if it's model was
always to draw a line then it could
learn by adjusting the parameters of
that line it would move the line around
until it found a line that was a good
fit and generally gave you a good
prediction but then if you were to ask
this model okay now make me a new one
unless you did something clever what you
get is probably this because that is on
average the closest to any of these
because any of these dots you don't know
if they're going to be above or below
it's you know to the left or the right
there's no pattern there it's kind of
random so the best place you can go that
will minimize your error is to go just
right on the line every time but anybody
looking at this will say well that's
fake that's not a plausible example of
something from this distribution even
though for a lot of the like error
functions that people use when training
networks this would perform best so it's
this interesting situation where there's
not just one right answer you know
generally speaking the way that neuron
networks work is you're training them
towards a specific you have a label or
you have a you have an output a target
output and you get penalty the further
away you are from that output whereas in
in a in an application like this
there's effect there's basically an
infinite number of perfectly valid
outputs here but so so to generate this
what you actually need is to take this
model and then apply some randomness you
say they're all within you know
they occur randomly and they're normally
distributed around this line with this
standard deviation or whatever but a lot
of models would have a hard time
actually picking one of all of the
possibilities and they would have this
tendency to kind of smooth things out
and go for the average whereas we
actually just want just pick me one
doesn't matter so that's part of the
problem of generating adversarial
training is is help is a way of training
not just networks actually a way of
training machine learning systems which
involves focusing on the system's
weaknesses so if you if you are learning
let's say let's say you're teaching your
network to recognize handwritten digits
the normal way you would do that you
have your big training sample of labeled
samples you've got an array of pixels
that looks like a three and then it's
labeled with three and so on and the
normal way that you would train a
network with this is you would just
present all of them pretty much at
random you'd present as many ones as two
S's threes and just keep throwing
examples at it what's this you know yes
you got that right now you've got that
wrong it should really be this and keep
doing that and the system will
eventually learn but if you were
actually teaching a person to recognize
the numbers if you were teaching a child
you wouldn't do that like if you if
you'd been teaching them for a while
presenting them and you know getting the
response and correcting them and so on
and you noticed that they can do you
know with with 2 3 4 5 6 8 & 9 they're
getting like 70 80 percent you know
accuracy recognition rate but 1 & 7 it's
like 50/50 because they keep any time
they get a 1 or a 7 they just guess
because they can't tell the difference
between them if you noticed that you
wouldn't keep training those other
numbers right you would stop and say
well you know what we're just gonna
focus on 1 & 7 because this is an issue
for you I'm gonna keep showing you Ones
and 7s in correcting you until the error
rate on ones and 7s comes up comes down
to the error rate that you're getting on
your other numbers you're focusing the
training on the area where the student
is failing and there's kind of a balance
there when you're teaching humans
because if you
keep relentlessly focusing on their
weaknesses and making them do stuff they
can't do all the time they will just
become super discouraged and give up but
neural networks don't have feelings yet
so that's really not an issue you can
just continually hammer on the weak
points find whatever they're having
trouble with and focus on that and so
that behavior and I think some people
have had teachers where it feels like
this it feels like an adversary right it
feels like they want you to fail so in
fact you can make them an actual
adversary if you have some process which
is genuinely doing its best to make the
network give as high an error as
possible that will produce this effect
where if it spots any weakness it will
focus on that and they're there by force
the learner to learn to not have that
weakness anymore like one form of
adversarial training people sometimes do
is if you have a game playing program
you make it play itself a lot of times
because all the time they are trying to
look for weaknesses in their opponent
and exploit those weaknesses and when
they do that they're forced to then
improve or fix those weaknesses in
themselves because their opponent is
exploiting those weaknesses so every
time the every time the system finds a
strategy that is extremely good against
this opponent the the opponent who's
also them has to learn a way of dealing
with that strategy and so on and so on
so as the system gets better it forces
itself to get better because it's
continuously having to learn how to play
a better and better opponent it's quite
it's quite elegant you know this is
where we get to generative adversarial
networks let's say you've got a network
you want to let's say you want cat
pictures you know you want to be able to
give it a bunch of pictures of cats and
have it spit out a new picture of a cat
that you've never seen before that looks
exactly like a cat the way they're
degenerative adversarial network works
is it's this architecture where you
actually have two networks one of the
networks
is the discriminator how's my spelling
yeah like that the discriminator Network
is a classifier right it's a
straightforward classifier you give it
an image and it outputs a number between
0 & 1 and your training that in standard
supervised learning way then you have a
generator and the generator is usually a
convolutional neural network although
actually both of these can be other
processes but people tend to use in your
networks for this and the generator you
give it some random noise and that's the
random that's where it gets its source
of randomness so that it can give
multiple answers to the same question
effectively you give it some random
noise and it generates an image from
that noise and the idea is it's supposed
to look like a cat so the way that we do
this with a generative adversarial
Network is it's this architecture
whereby you have two networks playing a
game effectively it's a competitive game
it's adversarial between them and in
fact it's a very similar kind of game to
the games we talked about in the
previous the alphago video right it's a
min/max game because these two networks
are fighting over one number one of them
wants the number to be high one of them
wants the number to be low and what that
number actually is is the error rate of
the discriminator so the discriminator
wants a low error rate the generator
wants a high error rate the
discriminators job is to look at an
image which could have come from the
original data set or it could have come
from the generator and its job is to say
yes this is a real image or no this is a
fake any outputs a number between 0 & 1
like 1 for its real and 0 for its fake
for example and the generator gets fed
as its input just some random noise and
it then generates an image from that and
it's reward you know it's training is
pretty much the inverse of what the
discriminator says
for that image so if it produces an
image which the discriminator can
immediately tell this fake it gets a
negative reward you know it's a that's
it's trained not to do that if it
manages to produce an image that the
discriminator can't tell is fake then
that's really good
so you train them in a inner cycle
effectively you you give the
discriminator a real image get its
output then you generate a fake image
and get the discriminator that and then
you give it a real so the discriminator
gets alternating real image fake image
real image fake image usually I mean
there are things you can do where you
train them at different rates and
whatever but by default they're
generally to get any help with this at
all or is it purely yes so if you this
is this is like part of what makes this
especially clever actually the generator
does get help because if you set up the
networks right you can use the gradient
of the discriminator to train the
generator so when I know you done back
propagation before about how neural
networks are trained its gradient
descent right and in fact we talked
about this in like 2014 sure if you were
a you're a blind person climbing a
mountain or you're it's really foggy and
you're climbing a mountain you can only
see directly what's underneath your own
feet
you can still climb that mountain if you
just follow the gradient you just look
directly under me which way is the you
know which way is the ground sloping
this is what we did the hill climb
algorithm exactly yeah sometimes people
call it hill climbing sometimes people
call it gradient descent it's the same
metaphor upside down effectively if
we're climbing up or we're climbing down
you're training them by gradient descent
which means that you're not just you're
not just able to say yes that's good no
that's bad you're actually able to say
and you should adjust yours you should
adjust your weights in this direction so
that you'll move down the gradient right
so generally you're trying to move down
the gradient of error for the network if
you're like if you're training
if your training the thing to just
recognize cats and dogs you're just
moving it you're moving it down the
gradient towards the correct label
whereas in this case the generator is
being moved sort of up the gradient for
the discriminators error so it can find
out not just you did well you did badly
but here's how to tweak your weights so
that you will so that the discriminator
would have been more wrong so so that
you can confuse the discriminator more
so you can think of this whole thing
an analogy people sometimes use is like
a a forger and an expert investigator
person right at the beginning you know
let's assume there's one forger in
there's one investigator and all of the
art buyers of the world are idiots at
the beginning the the level of the the
quality of the forgeries is going to be
quite low right the guy just go get some
paint and he he then he just writes you
know Picasso on it and he can sell it
for a lot of money and the investigator
comes along and says yeah I do I don't
know that's right or maybe it is I'm not
sure I haven't really figured it out
and then as time goes on the
investigator who's the discriminator
will start to spot certain things that
are different between the things that
the forger produces and real paintings
and then they'll start to be able to
reliably spot oh this is a fake
you know this uses the wrong type of
paint or whatever so it's fake and once
that happens the forger is forced to get
better right you can't sell his fakes
anymore he has to find that kind of
paint so he goes and you know digs up
Egyptian mummies or whatever to get the
legit paint and now he can forge again
and now of the discriminator the
investigator is fooled and they have to
find a new thing that distinguishes the
real from the fakes and so on and so on
in a cycle they force each other to
improve and it's the same thing here so
at the beginning the generator is making
just random noise basically because it's
it's it's getting random noisy and it's
doing something to it who knows what and
it spits out an image and the
discriminator goes that looks nothing
like a cat you know and then eventually
because the discriminator is also not
very smart at the beginning right and
and they just they both get better and
better the generator gets better at
producing cat looking things and the
discriminator gets better and better at
identifying them until eventually in
principle if you run this for long
enough theoretically you end up with a
situation where the generator is
creating images that look exactly
indistinguishable from images from the
real data set and the discriminator if
it's given a real image or a fake image
always outputs 0.5 5050 I don't know
could be either these things are
literally indistinguishable then you
pretty much can throw away the
discriminator and you've got a generator
which you give random noise to and it
outputs brand-new indistinguishable
images of cats there's another cool
thing about this which is every every
time we ask the generator to generate
new image we're giving it some random
data right we give it just this vector
of random numbers which you can think of
as being a randomly selected point in a
space because you know if you give it if
you give it ten random numbers you know
between zero and one or whatever that is
effectively a point in a 10 dimensional
space and the thing that's cool is that
as the generator learns it's forced to
you if the generator is effectively
making a mapping from that space into
cat pictures this is called the lateness
base by the way generally any two nearby
points in that latent space will when
you put them through the generator
produce similar cabbages you know
similar pictures in general which means
sort of as you move around if you sort
of take that point and smoothly move it
around the latent space you get a smooth
léa varying picture of a cat and so the
directions you can move in the space
actually end up corresponding to
something that we as humans might
consider meaningful about cats so
there's one you know there's one
direction and it's not necessarily one
dimension of the space or whatever but
and it's not necessarily linear or a
straight line or anything but there will
be a direction in that space which
corresponds to how big the cat is in the
frame for example or another dimension
will be the color of the cat or whatever
so that's really cool because it means
that by intuitively you think the fact
that the generator can reliably produce
a very large number of images of cats
means it must have some like
understanding understanding of what cats
are right or at least what images of
cats are and it's nice to see that it
has actually structured its latent space
in this way that it's by looking at a
huge number of pictures of cats it has
actually extracted some of the structure
of cat pictures in general in a way
which is meaningful when you look at it
so and that means you can do some really
cool things so one example was they
trained Annette one of these systems on
a really large database of just face
photographs and so it could generate
arbitrarily large number of well as
largest the input space a number of
different faces and so they found that
actually by doing basic arithmetic like
just adding and subtracting vectors on
the latent space would actually produce
meaningful changes in the image if you
took a bunch of latent vectors which
when you give them to the generator
produce pictures of men and a bunch of
them that produce pictures of women and
average those you get a point in your
latent space which corresponds to
a picture of a man or a picture of a
woman which is not one of your input
points but it's sort of representative
and then you could do the same thing and
say oh I only want give me the average
point of all of the things that
correspond to pictures of men wearing
sunglasses right and then if you take
your sunglass vector you're you're men
wearing sunglasses vector subtract the
man vector and add the woman vector you
get a point in your space and if you run
that through the generator you get a
woman wearing sunglasses right so doing
doing basic vector arithmetic in your
input space actually is meaningful in
terms of images in a way that humans
would recognize which means that there's
there's a sense in which the generator
really does have an understanding of
wearing sunglasses or not or being a man
or being a woman which is kind of an
impressive result all the way along but
it's not a truly random thing because if
I know the key and I can start want to
generate the same yeah I'm so I mean
that's about unfortunate is the problem
with cryptography is that we couldn't
ever use truly random because we
wouldn't be able to decrypt it again we
have our message bits which are you know
naught 1 1 naught something different
and we XOR these together one bit at a
time and that's how we encrypt